[Music]
do the right thing NewsHour I think that
was a movie in the 90s we do the black
people submitted by JK come to space
yeah bring us up to spoon writing from
speech mmm what if it's an astronaut and
a [ __ ] space shuttle even it
cuz you're gonna happen or like a during
a space station it's an alien to while
you [ __ ] your flat earthers out there
all you got to do is go on the Google
[ __ ] Space Shuttle [ __ ] it'll show
you that the world is round but that's
all fake they know that conspiracy bro
oh they go through all that [ __ ] hard
work to tell about it
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] that government man no
18 turns her dad in after seeing him
burglarize a home in the police video
what a big [ __ ] rat
I [ __ ] up why would rap my dad if he
didn't share for real if he did mine uh
she doesn't need to share you know how
many years even taking sure you well he
took care of me by choice you know that
I would never wrap my dad I didn't want
to be poor or a crime that's not
malicious
yeah is malicious cuz you're stealing
for nothing though that's not like
[ __ ] children but no one had to work
hard to buy these items that you're
different no one's getting hurt though
my feelings were getting hurt I feel so
family that's right emotional feelings
that's something that's made up in your
mind not that your book all about
physical pain [ __ ] your dad it's like if
you be so fun if my dad like kill
someone or rape someone that's actual
pain they stole some precious family
heirloom we're not we're not we're not
debating whether it's right or wrong
he's just setting his his medium for
what that's when I would rather him out
that's my limit
he knows that burglarizing is wrong he's
not denying that he just said it would
take what if you know what he's I know
I'm saying burglarizing all BYO
that's what he's saying exactly thank
whatever don't defend a [ __ ] crazy
but it's not so what still my backpack
there's still my baggage they didn't
physically harm me saying the level of
wrong but the murder and stealing a
backpack is like this you don't [ __ ]
your one eye
this what's on your mom for [ __ ]
stealing the grape at the grocery store
yeah nope you cut Meg that is wrong
I need a picture mama the good [ __ ] he's
all getting taken away like it's not
[ __ ] great don't still around me yeah
but I definitely wouldn't turn my denim
around house I will talk to him if I
what the [ __ ] man is just how you been
supporting our family a [ __ ]
disappointed in you but turning a man
[ __ ] that dude I need that for the pay
the bills yeah I saw you I do the same
thing yeah come on I would turn them in
if she gave me wrong and if you kill
somebody I still the reason why yeah
true yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm talking
white I'd be like a serial killer that's
a different story
well why did this girl do it my friend
it's okay yeah as long as he's not
killing my friends it's okay are you
gonna cut other people away your friends
I always forget are we yeah yeah so this
girl her name is Cora she's 19 years old
from the UK that's a dope name oh this
woman cartoon ha sounds like a superhero
one doin Cora she's cool or like lurid
Explorer she's a fart bender yeah so
this here is Cora she is she looks like
a rat rat Maz [ __ ] you don't even know
like you read what I brought like this
one she's like yeah I did it
rat mad [ __ ] where'd she get that
medieval blouse from it was a very photo
of her too with the different black
blouse but it was like this [ __ ]
medieval - I was like she like - shut up
game with Rosa Jacqueline's wardrobe it
just looks like a shoe she does look
like she could be in some kind of like
so Chuck Taylor is amateur porn or
something yeah we don't know why she
ratted why would giving her so much
shade yeah David that's [ __ ] up
put the [ __ ] a sizing her toe is a
claw her clothing choices I don't know
why but I'm cool with her she's cool she
probably ride it for a good reason right
yeah so Cora she recently found out that
she was pregnant and so one
and so when she thought she was pregnant
her dad Colin who has 34 previous
convictions for burglary that's a
different story
he's a [ __ ] repetitive offender yeah
so Colin had promised Cora that you know
now he's going to be a grand grandpa to
stop that [ __ ]
Yeah right she's gonna turn it leg round
he's not going to [ __ ] up anymore not
even a couple like months later - five
dollars through on her Facebook she sees
a video a CCTV footage of this couple
burglarizing a elderly woman's home
oh so to tell you the truth though you
know oh people make the best victim
because they're just easy burglary is
bad kids we were what's going on right
here
why do you I'm getting frostbite with
the [ __ ] ice pack so I'm putting it
away okay yeah so she she commented on
it I suffered an injury from
burglarizing old people there he said it
so she commented on that Facebook post
would you like to read this I'll tell
you the [ __ ] name Colin Patterson and
Jeanine Patterson absolutely ashamed to
call them my dad and Auntie heartbroken
brother and sinner
yeah brilliant a hundred and ten percent
he's just even texted me saying thanks
but don't feel guilty I definitely don't
after the [ __ ] he's put me through and I
hope he's still reading these comments
because I'm absolutely devastate that I
don't like her anymore
so this is a dad just a little crew and
this is her aunt if go back Oh
if elbow was a human being drama yeah hi
everybody
that's that's elbow her she he she he
has the face of Jack in a box
ya know so that's when the police went
over and they arrested him and
apparently Colin was texting his
daughter saying that you can commit
suicide that he was so distraught that
she turned him in but then she and then
like trying to make her feel bad but
I know I make you feel guilty just use
you just saying that for attention he's
selfish he good like you know I'm not
gonna
don't be suckered in girl yeah she just
saying she's sad that her child can grow
up without a granddad you told me to
remove daughter total me oh they're on
our side now we have 34 convictions I'm
sure so what I was assuming it's the
first time and then you know he just
snitched on her pops but I'm pretty sure
it seems like she was like dad I know
you got a problem but we're about to
bring the new life into this world I
would like if you're around can you
please stop that [ __ ] and then he still
did it I was like well you know what
she's a little [ __ ] though because
because obviously there's a family
business and it's a family like probably
oh okay yeah they best even like it's
passed down from generation to
generation like they're probably
descendants of Robin Hood was like a
factor in the UK yeah I mean like they
they've been robbing like back in a day
like from the medieval times it's again
their last name right okay not out like
Smith yeah he shrunk it Angela Robin
it's Colin Robinson and it's Robin yeah
I only thought the story was like a
five-year-old girl that found out her
dad robbed something and then the five
year old girl called the police fifteen
well I wasn't listening obviously so in
my mind I had already thought it was a
cute little five-year-old girl that
ratted them out how you [ __ ] to the
chest don't give a [ __ ] how old my yeah
but she started at an early age yes
dishnow she just wishes older [ __ ]
[ __ ] but now she's a responsible human
being because you know what they say for
me once shame on you fool me 34 times
what the [ __ ] you know now jail time
[ __ ] him yes I am the court the judge
was just praising her to think it takes
a lot of courage for someone to do what
she did she's still a rat in my eyes I
wonder if the dad and heart was like
this to the daughter the whole time cut
out okay but before I think about it
what a [ __ ] I just can't believe her
like did he be her
no all he did was just you know what I'm
not gonna [ __ ] steal anymore and then
she's like every [ __ ] stole again
that's like if my if my dad was like I'm
not going to drink anymore and then he's
like drinking I'm not going to call the
cops on his ass I'll just be like
disappointed I think it's the drama that
it creates within the family though like
the police coming all the time banging
on the door all the time or people are
serving warrants this [ __ ] I think
there's too much drama so she can over
Wayne she's not positive you know a
positive person will help them do their
job better like you know she'll be like
more like you know listen to these
[ __ ] Tony Robbins tapes motivate her
dad like that look
you've been [ __ ] robbing houses since
you were 18 you need to move up and do
some jewelry heist just do one big job
man what the [ __ ] is wrong with you turn
up some links to watch yeah it's right
come on man it's like you need to move
up in life if this is your career choice
you need to like get some confidence and
go after bigger things
watch Ocean's eleven or something right
if you fear [ __ ] doing home stealing
like a watch a [ __ ] Citizen Watch or
some [ __ ] like Jamie said jewelry in the
middle yeah he doesn't he doesn't have
confidence so she needs to be a good
daughter and tell her dad like dad check
this out I've been thinking that it's
about time you graduate now if your kid
robbed the house would you turn him in
the pound I'll beat the [ __ ] I don't
know mmm nice I tell them dude you're
aiming too low to me turning in my car
I'm you're turning in my kids is worse
than child abuse I'd rather beat the
[ __ ] I'd rather beat the living [ __ ] out
of them than to call the cops on what's
the punishment besides after the beating
[ __ ] though there's that's a whole
spectrum right there oh [ __ ] there's
like spanking all the way to like tying
them to the tree or emptying out my
punching bag at home and putting it
inside the punch sipping the top giving
them a straw through the broom well what
are your like fake honey and he's like
40 now and and I'm like what if you're
like 80 and he's like
hopefully that make some friends and
entertainment and I get Michael Jai
White to [ __ ] the backspin kicking or
you know that celebrities are immortal
that's true they stay the same
oh yeah she should be a [ __ ] old
grandma on a [ __ ] in a walker right now
but she's damn looking so [ __ ] still
was so weird I think I don't know what
the offense would be for me to turn in
my son rape it's got to be some crazy
[ __ ] like that given [ __ ] yeah I mean
I'm trying to figure out what's that
medium in between because burglary I
probably want to turn him in but I would
somehow get him to try to return the
stuff back without getting caught and
then I put his head in the motor Bart to
[ __ ] him up and then after that I don't
know what the next level above that is
that I would turn him in I would turn
them in if he's [ __ ] bigger stronger
and he could beat my ass back what about
vandalism battle is a must raping his
[ __ ] eyes no not like that I'm
talking about he okay I may not be about
parsing I'm sorry arson like with meat
burned a house down
general [ __ ] burn his pubes what not
just kidding I don't care I probably
ever turn my kid in yeah I mean is wrong
with you terrible yes terrible of course
but you could talk to him still if but
if this dude is like out there raping
all kinds of people and there's nothing
I can do not to reconsider this kid
thing yeah what do you I hear together
I'm an arson horrible I'm not saying
only things that come out your mouth
what would you do
okay let's say your your kid burnt down
the post office what do you do going to
call the cops on him
of course that's [ __ ] up that's his
fault but here nobody just burned a lot
of snaps that's hurting a lot of no you
say why did you do this too late
that's nice good hope you guys enjoyed
that video but if you didn't guess what
you can directly contribute to the
articles that we discussed just cruise
out over to the description box below
click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video let's
wrap up hey
you
[Music]